veo un tipo de cuerpo concreto en
internet o en los medios y sé que quiero
eso y trabajo para eso cuando ves las
redes sociales todo es muy glamuroso al
crecer pensaba si quiero ser atractivo
tengo que tener abdominales siento que
me pondrán en el último lugar porque no
encajó en ese estándar puedes estar en
una habitación con muchos hombres y
estar en ropa interior sin sentirte raro
o incómodo
clasificando tipos de cuerpos masculinos
para este episodio vamos a revelar la
clasificación de la audiencia primaria
vamos a ver cuánto nos odia la gente
cambie con Omar y
que David cambie con Erick
que Aby cambie con Omar y
que Albert cambie con omari
y que Albert cambie con Aby
Así es como las personas votaron Cuál es
el cuerpo más atractivo entiendo la
clasificación de la audiencia porque si
te fijas en el físico sin conocer las
personalidades Por supuesto que
tendríamos a un atleta ya y yo aquí
porque no creo que los latinos somos
sexys no entiendo por qué estoy aquí
pero respeto esto chicos Me gusta esto
Qué opinan ustedes me siento cómodo pero
me resulta difícil juzgarlo así supongo
que el público votó
esperaba estar más abajo tal vez tres o
cuatro cuando crecí siempre me decían
pareces un palo o estás muy flaco claro
me imagino que se sienten bien porque
están en los dos lugares más altos eso
está bien soy el segundo más atractivo
estoy bien aquí creo que tiene sentido
por la forma en la que la gente ve el
mundo es por lo que se ve en los medios
en las redes sociales creo que tiene
sentido para cualquiera pero no es la
regla no me grande porque cuando era más
joven ese era el tipo de cuerpo que
quería siempre me compare con eso creo
que
se esperaba no me sorprende pero
creo que tenía esperanza
pueden discutir como quieren hacer la
clasificación mientras hablan tienen la
libertad de cambiar de lugar cómo te
sientes al estar en el centro sientes
que deberías estar más adelante me
sorprendió porque mientras crecía mi
madre me decía que sería más atractivo
si ganara más peso Por eso pensé que
sería el último porque la sociedad
piensa que los delgados No merecemos
amor pero yo creo que sí sí te queremos
Sí cuando era niño Me comparaba con esos
hombres atractivos que tenían
abdominales y pecho no sabía lo que
estaba viendo pero me intrigaba y quería
ser así para mí no sé la edad de ustedes
pero crecí en la era de Abercrombie fit
entradas y veías abdominales en la pared
No mentiré eso me motivó quería ser así
mientras crecía piensan que está mal
querer verse como otro tipo de cuerpo
así es porque yo me similar a ti solía
tener 50 kilos de más y recuerdo que la
gente me trataba de una manera tener
cita Será muy muy difícil la gente no
quería alguien como yo luego perdí peso
y comencé a hacer tratado de manera
diferente pero era la misma persona yo
deseaba parecerme a otra persona al
perder peso pero me di cuenta de que
odio la forma en que la sociedad me
trata como una persona pequeña
esa es una respuesta Interesante pero yo
creo que está bien querer un determinado
tipo de cuerpo
porque yo lo uso como motivación trataré
de hacer lo que pueda para llegar a ese
punto creo que para mí hay una
diferencia entre motivación con algo que
te apasiona y con algo que pueda
consumirte y llevarte a un agujero no
creo que eso ayude han sido criticados o
son ustedes los que se autocrítican
porque a veces tus propios pensamientos
te pueden sabotear en mi caso hay mucha
autocrítica sé que estoy clasificado de
primero pero cuando me miro en el espejo
sigo viendo cosas que no me gustan de mí
y que quiero cambiar una gran parte es
auto impuesta influenciada por la gente
que me rodea tengo que trabajar en mí
por supuesto creo que eso nunca se irá
pero si bien es bueno rodearse de
personas que quieren lo mejor para ti
después de hacer ejercicio pienso vaya
me veo como la persona más sexy del
planeta eres la persona más sexy de la
tierra es cierto podría salir conmigo
mismo si quisiera pero no lo haré porque
quiero darle la a otras personas
[Risas]
Recuerdo cuando me deprimía y pensaba
que me parecía a una rata horrible para
mí muchas de mis críticas Fueron
proyectadas por otras personas he sido
detalle grande toda mi vida se burlaban
de mí en la escuela me llamaban Ariel La
gran sirena
o este niño huele mal o alguien se tiró
un pedo fue el gordo y he sufrido de eso
a lo largo de mi vida y quiero estar
saludable pero ya no se trata de tener
un determinado tipo de cuerpo y Cuando
Perdí 54 kilos uno de mis ídolos alguien
a quien idolatrava cuando me vio me dijo
Te veías mejor cuando estabas más gordo
nunca se puede complacer a nadie solo
tienes que tienes que vivir para ti y es
verdad hacer lo que te haga feliz y cómo
te sientes mejor estoy dispuesto a que
me coloquen en cualquier sitio no sé de
qué lado ir podría ponerme de tercero
estar en el medio tal vez
creo que es mejor si nos clasificamos no
por lo atractivo sino en términos de
energía como si estuviéramos en un
escenario social muy bien Él está como
no sé si te pedíamos salir hablamos
antes hablamos antes yo los pondría más
adelante porque creo que podemos tener
amistad tomar una cerveza salir parece
genial te pondré de tercero
no estoy en la universidad ya no
recuerdo cómo era no sé si tenemos cosas
en común pero estarás de cuarto yo Odio
estar solo iré de quinto esto es difícil
Erick creo que eres un tipo increíble
creo que deberías estar aquí eres
abierto cálido y divertido
En qué lugar me pondrías
cambiarías Omar y creo que ya tienes
mucho en la primera posición
estuvo en el número uno
estuvo número 2 Alberto
y uno más y yo aquí Perfecto perfecto
esto es extraño
sin hablar de lo físico creo que la
personalidad de este grupo es muy
abierta y también es muy extrovertida
siempre he querido ser así parte de mi
confianza está arraigada en mi
apariencia física seré honesto por eso
me pondré de tercero
Javi creo que te pondré de primero Erick
de segundo y Ariel de cuarto
gracias
me pongo en último porque creo que soy
más tranquilo y reservado y no tomo la
iniciativa no muestro mi personalidad a
gente al azar Avi te puse como cuatro
porque
el número 4 tiene tu energía
[Risas]
Esa es la forma más bonita de ser cuarto
es tu energía y Omar y de tercero porque
me das la sensación de tener una postura
neutral de ser introvertido pero también
extrovertido y porque te mantienes entre
los delgados y los atletas
pondría Ariel en el número 2 Eric en el
número uno porque aceptas tu cuerpo sin
importar lo que piensen los demás siento
que ese es el tipo de mentalidad que
quiero tener un día Me encantó genial Me
siento tan cálido están contentos con o
quieren hacer un último cambio estoy
contento Estoy de acuerdo con esta
clasificación
en base a lo que llegué a conocer de
todos en ese sentido Sí siento que fue
un buen ajuste no sé Es difícil
Reconozco que el atractivo no es solo
físico también tiene que ver con la
personalidad como interactúas con otras
personas sé que hay cosas en las que
quiero trabajar por eso me clasifiqué
con un tres pero hay otras personas que
sentí que me superan creo que lo más
hermoso es tu singularidad solo eso
importa eso es lo que tienes es lo que
tienes para trabajar No hay nadie más
como ustedes Yo diría yo lo solo se vive
una vez sea amable contigo mismo y que
no te importe lo que piensen los demás
sí